it has been more than a year since
Nevada state trooper Micah May lost his
life in the line of duty but the
community is still coming together to
honor his true sacrifice good evening
thanks for joining us I'm Denise Valdez
and I'm Brian Loftus this time he's
being recognized at a national level in
the 2023 Rose Bowl Parade Sasha Loftus
spoke with his family tonight joins us
now live Sasha with more
Denise and Brian you'll remember Troopa
Micah May was hit and killed during a
car chase here on the I-15 last year it
was the dark day for our community but
tonight's event was about finding hope
after tragedy
Micah the ultimate honor after the
ultimate sacrifice it really means a lot
that he's still being remembered more
than a year after he died while in the
line of duty Nevada State Police Trooper
Micah May will soon be recognized at a
national level
in the 2023 Rose Bowl Parade as we
remember for my command on Thursday
friends and family joined May's wife
Joanna to see his part of the Donate
Life float and get it ready for the big
day so I really hope he understands how
much he meant to us and the community
Trooper May who was an organ donor will
represent the entire state of Nevada
with this florograph truly the epitome
of being a hero not only that day but
again throughout his whole entire career
Stephen Peralta of Nevada donor Network
says they chose May for his
extraordinary bravery on the day he was
hit and killed during a car chase in
July of 2021 but when you look at that
day and what had happened and you look
at the incident that led up to it at his
ultimate sacrifice Joanna says she's
thankful to see the community's efforts
for her late husband what he did was
truly scary and she wants him to know
how much his service still means I
really hope he smiling down
now Trooper May's family was able to
finish the his face in that floor graph
specifically his eyebrows they were able
to take part in that and if you'd like
to see that floor graph in that float
it'll again be in the Rose Day Parade on
January 2nd of 2023. reporting live
tonight social Loftus 8 News Now